for those who lived through what is
sometimes called the psychedelic
revolution
terence mckenna is a legend once
referred to
as the timothy leary of the 90s terence
attained iconic status as a radical
philosopher
futurist cultural critic and recon tour
his unorthodox ideas about the
evolutionary and cultural impact
of psychedelic drugs shocked many and
resonated with many others
as terence's younger brother and only
sibling i grew up with him
in a small town in western colorado
during the 50s
and 60s traveling together in the
columbian amazon in 1971
with a few other kindred spirits we
called our band
the brotherhood of the screaming abyss
our adventures inspired many of
terence's unorthodox ideas about time
and the nature of history which in turn
became
fertile ground for certain apocalyptic
beliefs
about the year 2012.
terence died in 2000 never to learn if
his predictions about the end of the
world
in his particular sense were true
since then he has achieved a kind of
virtual immortality
his voice and image as near as the click
of a mouse
ghost like he haunts the internet a
talking head on youtube
the articulate prophet of an end time he
didn't live
to see in addition to true
hallucinations
terence authored or co-authored several
books
including food of the gods the archaic
revival
the evolutionary mind and the invisible
landscape
among others his wide-ranging thoughts
and observations remain
as fresh and timely as though uttered
yesterday
he lives on as the beloved potter
families of a younger generation of
seekers though most were still in
diapers
when terence was at the peak of his
career
even on the cusp of uncovering the
mysteries of existence
my brother and i managed to keep a sense
of humor
it helped to be irish we didn't know
what we were searching for
beyond the conviction that it was a
profound insight
and that it would change us and
everything forever
we were right on both counts
though not in the ways we imagined
we as a species are going to live
in the imagination the imagination is
the future
frontier for humanity so
it may be a combination of drugs
techniques technologies
attitude shifts uh linguistic
redesign of our language assumptions
all of this may be necessary to propel
us into a world
whose rules are not the laws of physics
but the laws of the human imagination
liberate yourself from the illusion of
culture
take responsibility for what you think
and what you do a lot of people are
going to be very anxious
because change raises anxiety
in people and people who have limited
opportunities to
educate themselves because of culturally
inflicted abuse
are scared because they can sense
that everything familiar is giving way
but they don't want to embrace
the unimaginable these people need to be
reassured
they need to be reassured by example
and by hearing optimistic
and reasonable rhetoric about the future
selling the future as an eight alarm
fire
which is how the media does it only
makes the same
future impossible so we need
a responsible approach
to thinking about the future and it
means taking
personal responsibility for the ideas
the means that you push
into society and for the images that we
share among ourselves and you are
constantly
bombarded with images which disempower
divide confuse and
and and make crazy basically
the way out then is personal
responsibility
new operating systems downloaded from
outside of culture
which means from the deeper wisdom
of the psychedelic plants and then a
commitment to community
and a motto of to the future
without fear without fear
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you